salut une énigme par jour pendant 32
jours à l'intérieur du défi du mental
vlog je commence à vous donner la
solution de l'énigme d'hier si vous
n'avez pas vu l'énigme d'hier font ces
lavoirs de suite parce que là je vais
donner la réponse tout de suite donc ce
serait dommage de ne pas avoir vu
l'énigme avant comme en rajoutant un
seul crée on peut transformer ce neufs
écrit en chiffres romains en 1,6 en un
seul trait on a dix en un seul trait
donc sans lever le stylo en un seul
trait mon neuf devient ainsi ce nom
c'est pas une arnaque
c'est une solution tout à fait acceptée
est acceptable et je pense que beaucoup
d'entre vous l'ont trouvée je verrai ça
dans les pouces en l'air de la vidéo
d'hier
et si jamais vous ne l'aviez pas trouvé
vous allez sûrement trouvé celle
d'aujourd'hui l'énigme de cette vidéo 14
est somme toute un peu plus simple que
d'habitude c'est surtout un grand
classique dans les énigmes peut-être y
en a certains qui vont la connaître mais
c'était important la mettre pour ceux
qui la connaissent pas vous avez neuf
cases que vous pouvez vous aussi dessiné
sur un papier vous devez placer 10
vaches dans ses neuf cases vous vous
débrouillez comme vous voulez il peut y
avoir qu'un seul élément par case vous
devez rentrer dix vaches dans ses neuf
cases la réponse vous l'aurez demain à
17h dans le prochain mentale blog si
vous avez la bonne réponse ou si vous
connaissiez l'énigme ne le mettez pas
dans les commentaires mais tu es
simplement un pouce en l'air ce qui
permettra de voir le pourcentage de
personnes qui ont trouvé la solution qui
connaissaient déjà l'énigme quand on
compare le nombre de pouces en l'air par
rapport au nombre de fûts passer un bel
été
pensez à vous abonner avant de partir et
rendez vous de demain ciao